good morning to you this is sky news
breakfast it is seven o'clock in the uk
nine o'clock here in kiev as russia's
invasion of ukraine enters a fifth day
the next 24 hours is a crucial period
ukraine's president updates boris
johnson as a night of shelling is
reported in the north
the human face of tragedy seven-year-old
polina and her parents among more than
200 civilians reportedly killed in this
conflict
dangerous and unacceptable the u.s and
nato condemn vladimir putin's order to
put his nuclear forces on high alert
the uk fast tracks laws to stop russian
oligarchs hiding dirty money in britain
as the eu shuts its airspace to russian
planes and funds armed supplies to
ukraine
escaping ukraine almost 400 000 people
have now fled the conflict so far as the
eu opens its borders
boris johnson eases uk visa restrictions
for ukrainian refugees but stops short
of waving all rules for all citizens
seeking sanctuary
and the ruble is in big trouble this
morning russia's currency falls to an
all-time low as the west shuns moscow
we'll have the latest throughout the
morning from here in kiev and across
ukraine as russian forces advance on the
capital
[Music]
good morning from kiev ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski has told
boris johnson the next 24 hours will be
crucial for his country his comments
come as satellite images emerge showing
a three-mile military convoy of russian
forces heading towards kiev
blasts have been heard here in the
capital in the early hours of this
morning and also in the second city of
kharkiv over in the east
these are the latest developments on day
five of this conflict talks are due to
take place between ukrainian and russian
delegations later today
over on the border between belarus and
ukraine
the u.s has described president putin's
decision to
quit sorry to put russia's forces on
high alert as an unprovoked escalation
and totally unacceptable
the eu has opened its borders to
ukrainian refugees and is taking the
unprecedented step of sending arms to
ukraine
u.s president joe biden says he'll host
a call with allies and partners this
afternoon to coordinate a united
response
first our international affairs editor
dominic waghorn has this report from
moscow
dawn over kiev after a quieter night
they had prepared all weekend cleaning
weapons mustering for deployment
but the onslaught still hasn't come
if putin doesn't care about his citizens
the more reasons why he can spare
strangers
people for him are only garbage
both his people and strangers
former boxing champion and kiev mayor
vitaly klitschko has this message for
the invaders go back home
you have nothing to find here we hope
the russians take the decision move back
to russia
they nothing to find here in our home
the russian advance may have stalled his
troops in its armor not moving at the
pace that have been feared with reports
it's disorganized and in places in
disarray
though not here stanitzia luhanska is
ukraine says the banner but russian
troops have taken the town in eastern
ukraine it's soldiers taking up
positions outside banks and other key
buildings
this footage shows the impact of a
russian cruise missile strike on an
airport in northwest ukraine allegedly
launched from belarus
and here from another angle
but on the border with belarus russian
and ukrainian diplomats are due to meet
later
russian leader vladimir putin may
yesterday have put his nuclear
deterrence forces on raised alert but
it's also it seems giving diplomacy a
chance before the fighting might resume
in earnest
dominic waghorn sky news
moscow
well the prime minister boris johnson
has said britain will do all it can to
get more arms to the ukrainian military
i'm joined now from westminster by the
defense secretary ben wallace good
morning mr wallace good to talk to you
again from uh
here in kiev first of all
have we raised our
nuclear deterrence alert in response to
what uh president putin has done
well um mark the language that president
putin has used doesn't actually link to
anything off a russian readiness uh
procedure it's really
we assess him putting the deterrent
into the communication space reminding
people that he has a deterrent
and it's also about distracting the
world and the public from what he's
actually doing in ukraine it isn't
doesn't link to anything specific in in
their readiness structures of their
forces so he he's made this comment um
we keep it under review but of course
you know nato
has a nuclear deterrent the united
kingdom is nato's nuclear deterrent but
obviously we're joined by france the
united states
and uh we keep our readiness uh very
high that's why we have a continued at
sea deterrent but you know what we
shouldn't really forget that this is a
big attempt to distract away from his
troubles in ukraine by just deploying
into the sort of media space
these phrases
right but have you just to be clear have
you responded to what he's done in any
way in terms of our nuclear i would
never comment on our nuclear deterrence
posture
for operational and security reason
do you think he's crazy enough to
instigate a nuclear conflict
i i think he
has certainly done a lot of irrational
things recently uh obviously first and
foremost the invasion of ukraine against
all the advice all the
uh international lobbying
uh i think i'm not going to speculate on
what he would or wouldn't do but that's
why we all keep our deterrence at a
state of readiness in the west to make
sure that we can deter
but do you think it cornered president
putin
uh would be a dangerous man
i think he's a dangerous man now
i mean if things got so desperate
would you
think he could deploy tactical nuclear
weapons in ukraine
mark i'm not going to head down a road
of speculation of what ifs with
president putin what we
know is that president putin is
currently actually focused in the
invasion of a sovereign country in
ukraine
he is a man that has shown himself to
resort to all sorts of things not least
nerve agent on the streets of britain
but i think he is focused with this and
i'm not i'm not going to go into
speculations about
nuclear weapons systems or anything else
i think that's just not only unhelpful
it's unnecessarily alarmist when
actually he's focused his forces his
military leadership are focused on
taking ukraine
fair enough what do you
think is the latest intelligence what do
you see as the latest intelligence on
on how the russians are doing and when
you think kiev could fall
i think your report is uh
pretty accurate we've just uh published
our uh daily tweet to the start well the
first tweet of the morning which gives
us our assessed
defense intelligence view of where we
are the the main bulk of those armored
columns that you've been talking about
are approximately 20 kilometers north of
kiev northwest of kiev uh some of the
sporadic fighting is those sort of stay
behind or indeed advanced forces that i
think you've
covered on other days still around but
not having the strategic impact that i
think russia had hoped uh that airport
that strategic airport that you covered
i think on the first day that has
changed hands a few times clearly didn't
get captured by the russians in the way
that they'd like to have used it and
it's forced them to do all sorts of
things the russians have not captured
the big cities like cherniv and
karakov up on the side up in the north
east of the country quite close to some
of their borders but they have made
better progress than their other forces
still behind scheduled in the south so
they're not on schedule
they are in
some significant areas of disarray their
logistics lines are therefore slowed
down and you know that's because they've
based all of this on this sort of
bizarre assumption that the ukrainians
would welcome them as liberators well
president putin has taken that
assumption
and now that is not the case that's
causing them to pause it's causing them
to have logistical trouble
and of course you've seen at firsthand
the the strong bravery of the uh
ukrainians and their determination
to defend their country and you know i
visited that country mark five times uh
three times security minister twice
sorry three times his defense minister
twice the security minister and you know
if anyone wants to know the dividing
line between ukrainians and russia it is
that interview you've just carried with
an elderly gentleman who is signed up
about the views of people in his country
in ukraine they recognize that
individuals matter their rights matter
and the ukrainians view of russians are
they don't count in the russian game
it's simply
just the powerful people in russia that
matter
what would you say to belarus there are
reports today that they are about to
send
thousands of troops into ukraine uh to
help the russians what would you say to
them
well i think you know belarus has a lot
more to lose by being closer to russia
than it has to gain it is it is a very
poor country anyhow
uh you know the the the president uh
pretty much
ran off scuttled really to kremlin when
he had his rising recently uh and uh has
sold his soul for that reason and now
you have a vassal state potentially on
the border
it won't help the belarusians it won't
help the belarusian armed forces they're
far less equipped than the russians they
are not as good they're not as well
trained and you know if i was a
belarusian soldier
you should think that president putin
will be the first to put you in the
front line
because you are absolutely
easy to sacrifice uh compared to russian
soldiers that he will think might have a
political impact on him at home
and on weapons and supplying weapons to
ukraine have you managed to get any
weapons into this country since the
invasion began
uh yes we've got lethal and non-lethal
aid into this into ukraine i can't
speculate where or how i think that
would be put people at risk the other
thing i've done mark which is you know
britain was the first european country
to step up to join america with lethal
aid i hosted last friday a donor
conference in europe we've we've now
even got the belgiums and other
countries who historically would have
been hesitant delivering lethal aid i'm
i welcome strongly the eu's position you
know it took quite a lot of us quite a
lot of effort but since the but since
the but since the invasion began sorry
to interrupt you since the invasion
began have you managed to get yes we
have weapons into into ukraine
yes isn't the truth that it's all a bit
it's all a bit late you've known that
there's a threat to
um ukraine certainly since 2014
shouldn't we have been arming the
ukrainians
for years in just you know
because of a possibility of something
like this happening
well first of all the united states have
been arming them since 2015 2014 they
were
they were the first to do lethal aid
straight after crimea we complemented
that at first by training 20 000
uh ukrainians and also
only i think it was last year or if not
18 months ago we signed a contract with
ukrainians to supply them with fast
attack boats with missiles on them so
britain was at the forefront we were
also then the first european country to
do it but should overall the west after
2014 or maybe even after 2008 in georgia
been more proactive in
delivering uh you know a stronger
resilience package to
a number of states i think i think
obviously you know we can see now that
uh you know that that should have been
the case across europe but britain has
not been in that position britain has
been in the lead of it you know i have
links with my defense counterparts
because i have visited so many times i
engage with them we give them military
support
and we'll continue to do that but i also
think you know you have to also
recognize when you have you're up
against president putin
uh you know that his irrational behavior
which it seems to be getting greater
means that it's definitely harder to
predict what was happened you know i was
there in november
i was there you know earlier and even
when he amassed forces last april on his
border there were a significant number
of european countries who refused to
believe that he had any intention apart
from uh intimidation now
i think you know the west many countries
in europe will now be regretting those
positions but fundamentally britain has
been in the lead alongside the united
states in helping those ukrainians and
that's why we got to do the donor
conference on friday and brought you
know 20 30 countries around the table to
deliver lethal and non-lethal aid and
now we're at the heart of the
coordination of all those countries
getting it into the country
okay i just want to get a couple more in
do you support would you support british
volunteers coming over here to fight as
liz trust is suggesting
but i think liz trust is right to say it
is definitely for all of us a just cause
that this is this is about a sovereign
democratic country being threatened or
actually now invaded by a russian state
and that is something that we should all
stand up against whether that's at home
i think what i'd say is we can all do
our bit whether that's donating through
through the ukrainian embassy i'd also
say that you know i our armed forces are
contributing in a proper way to doing
this if you're keen to help your united
kingdom citizen come and join our armed
forces there are lots of ways to help
look there are people who will go
better than volunteering to come and
fight
well i think what i would say is unless
you are properly trained unless you are
a you know experienced uh member of an
armed forces i think you are there are
better ways for you to contribute to the
security of ukraine
you know we it the travel advice the
foreign office is not to go to ukraine
you'll put yourself in harm's way if
people are determined to do that my
advice to them is there are many ways to
help ukraine and unless you are a
trained
military personnel from a former career
as in you're not coming from our armed
forces because you've got a job to do
here
then i would say i would advise you to
explore with ukrainian embassy ways to
do that
okay two more quick questions are we
going to reverse the decision to cut 10
000 troops from our
military
well
obviously mark you wouldn't have noticed
because you're focused on other things
but a few weeks ago i announced that the
original baseline of 72.5 000 has gone
up to another 573 000 and i've always
said as the threat changes we must
consider changing the current strength
of the army is 78 000. but what i have
to say is is something to really
recognize from what the conflict we're
seeing on our television screens is i am
not getting messages from the ukrainians
every day asking for tanks i'm not
getting them asking for armoured
vehicles i'm getting messages every day
from the ukrainians asking for anti-tank
weapons personnel carry you know being
able to be carried by individuals i'm
getting messages every day about
anti-air missiles that can be carried by
individuals that's the type of warfare
that is currently threatening the might
of the russians we're entering we
yes we're entering an era quite possibly
of confrontation with russia and you are
effectively let's be honest cutting the
army are you going to reverse are you
going to speak for chancellor to get
some money to refer to reverse the cuts
to the army
well so mark there's no cuts other than
personnel there's an increases to the
army's capabilities you know the army is
it's not just about people otherwise you
end up the first world war where you
have millions of people but you don't
have any tanks the key here is to get
that balance so
in the defense command paper we said a
number of things should happen one is
spend the money on the armed forces the
people we have to be better equipped
more lethal more joined up and at more
readiness
otherwise you end up in an army i was in
where we had on paper lots of divisions
but when you press the button they were
completely hollow because we ran out of
money or we didn't have quite the kit to
deliver it so and and the other thing
your viewers should understand i know
they do that you know
a country a lot of commentators said
we've got an extra 24 billion pounds
you've got the biggest settlement
increase since the cold war at the
defense command paper that's not a cut
in anybody's book we have changed to
some extent the balance in numbers of
troops it's
it's a cut in numbers of troops and i
just want to finally just finally mark
could you can you acknowledge it's an
increase in the defense budget would
that be useful if you could acknowledge
it's a increase in defense budget i'm
just imagining about yes it's a massive
increase in the equipment i was just
talking about troops
okay so what we've seen in ukraine let
me just ask you this
okay let me just ask you this because
we've run out of time i think on visas
shouldn't we be doing what the eu is
doing and allowing all
ukrainian refugees in
well first of all what was announced or
will be announced later today is is a
first step we're absolutely looking at
all the different range of options we
can apply to to welcome ukrainians in
need the first step is to make sure that
uh ukrainians who have family here
either settled or are dual nationals
that they can come and join them but the
second step we will look at about what
we do with the refugee flows across the
board um you know the europe it's going
to be a problem right across europe and
we've obviously seen the european
position uh change i think as of
yesterday and we will reflect that
reflect on that and and make make
decisions uh in the near future
so you may so you may do what the eu is
doing in fact i think what we'll do is
you know just like the size of the army
mark we'll keep it under review
dependent on how situations changes on
the ground i think that's perfectly just
a bit remember britain's been incredibly
generous with the afghan scheme and the
arap
which i was dealing with during pitting
we've been a very one of the most
generous countries when it came to
obviously the hong kong nationals so we
have a track record of being generous in
this area we'll make sure it's done
properly and we'll obviously keep it
under review as the facts on the grounds
change
okay we'll let you go good to talk to
you thanks for being with us thank you
right well the latest satellite pictures
released show a russian convoy a very
long one heading in this direction these
pictures from the private u.s company
maxar show a convoy near ivankiv now
that's a town around 40 miles
north of here and they show a deployment
of hundreds you can see them there
military vehicles reportedly
containing well fuel logistics vehicles
and self-propelled artillery and uh that
uh is a very long convoy indeed uh
correspondent john sparks uh joins me
now from uh dunipro now that's in south
east of ukraine over in eastern ukraine
john just bring us up to date with what
is happening in that area and in kharkiv
where you were um there seems to be all
sorts of well a very intense fight going
on over that city
yeah good morning mark here in uh
dinipro it's been pretty quiet overnight
that hasn't stopped the air raid sirens
from sounding about four times in the
last 12 to 16 hours we know the drill
now at our hotel we grab our helmets our
body armor we troop down to the the car
park in the basement we wait there for
the all clear and then we we [ __ ] back
up again but pretty quiet here overnight
there have been explosions and blasts
heard where you are in kiev also in
harkeef the second largest city in
ukraine where there was fierce fighting
yesterday several armored russian
columns tried to gain access to the city
the governor there says those attacks
have been repulsed but he has put into
effect a 3 pm curfew today because of
his fear their fear of russian sabotage
groups operating in the city there have
been missile strikes in ukraine
overnight as well including in a city
called chonahip that's about a three
hour drive north of where you are mark
the missile has hit a residential
building the lower two floors are on
fire an unknown number of casualties we
understand that from the ukrainian
government's communication department
but i think it's clear to say over the
last 24 hours the military situation for
the russians is not panning out in the
way perhaps they anticipated this
conflict is having a galvanizing effect
on the european union in particular i
think it was interesting to hear ben
wallace say the ukrainians are asking
him for shoulder-born weapons well you
know the germans before the conflict
began were talking about sending helmets
5 000 helmets to the ukrainian military
now they're sending those missiles 500
stinger missiles 1 000 anti-tank
missiles and the eu high representative
like the foreign minister for the eu he
is now in talks with the ukrainians to
send them fighter jets russian-made
fighter jets that ukrainian pilots can
use that is a pretty extraordinary
response to this conflict
yeah it is an extraordinary response so
john thank you very much indeed let's go
to moscow now our international affairs
editor
dominic waghorn is there and dominic
first of all i mean the markets we've
been watching the ruble uh this morning
what is it 30
down and uh um i don't know about the
share market stock markets what's
happening
yeah i think the ruble's pulled back a
bit from the all-time low of 30 percent
against the dollar dropping by 30 that
is um to about 26
um so really tanking and um the central
bank is going to be announcing more
measures later on but it's already uh
doubled interest rates raising them from
9.5
uh to 20 and also selling companies so
private companies and state companies to
sell off their foreign reserves the bind
the russians are in is that the ruble is
tanking and normally in that situation
you would take measures selling off gold
selling off your foreign reserves to try
and shore up your currency the problem
with this is that in addition to these
swift sanctions that are being posed uh
cutting uh russia out of the swift
global transaction system these
sanctions also effectively block the
russian central bank and state banks uh
from access to those gold reserves or
foreign reserves outside of russia so
they don't have the kind of levers they
would normally be pulling to try and
shore the ruble back up so they are in a
difficult situation
they've taken some measures already um
and they have uh effectively suspended
trading in some markets and we're
expecting to see more measures announced
later on today i think the question with
all these sanctions of course is is who
is this going to hurt the most and is
this going to help putin or is it going
to hinder him we spoke to opposition
politician vladimir karamoza yesterday
um who was pretty vocal in his calls for
britain to do more to target the elites
in london gratitude in particular and
the west as well and he said it's
absolutely vital these sanctions do uh
target the elite surrounding uh putin
and don't hurt the ordinary people of
course if you're an ordinary russian
waking up today and you see the value of
your currency tanking against external
and foreign currencies it's going to be
a huge cause of concern
and it's possibly going to lead to panic
not necessarily today but the days ahead
we could see a run on the banks and that
is obviously going to hurt ordinary uh
russians and i think the other thing we
need to think about mark in this is is
is playing into putin's narrative
putin's narrative is the west is out to
get russia but in particular
out to get him um he seems to believe
that the west is hell-bent on regime
change and is out to get him that may
seem rather perverse if you're outside
of russia because you look at all of
this and it looks like russia has
started this but it seems to be
certainly the rhetoric of the russian
leadership this is a preemptive move
what it's doing against ukraine in the
sense they say they have no alternative
now if putin believes that we simply
don't really know what is going on
inside his mind but he's surrounded by
securicrats who are telling them him
this the whole time generals commanders
and defence ministers who are telling
him that the outside world is out to get
him this obviously plays into that
narrative it helps him sell that
narrative to the people but also i think
persuades him that the west is out to
get him and therefore he may be
entrenching his position and this may
not be deterring him as is the intention
of those imposing the sanctions
okay dominic thank you very much indeed
for that
well european nations and canada have
moved to shut their airspace to russian
aircraft the russian airline aeroflot
has been forced to cancel all flights to
european destinations jets have been
redirected mid-flight after the eu
implemented a russian flight ban and the
no-fly zone spans the entire 27 country
block and prevents any and all
russian-owned aircraft from entering the
union's airspace or
landing at their airports
well air france is halting all flights
to and from russia the company said the
decision will also lead to routes that
fly over russia being stopped such as
flights to china and japan
alternative routes are being looked at
the airline finnair says it will cancel
flights to russia japan south korea and
china this week after suspending flights
that fly over
russian airspace flights to singapore
thailand and india will continue but
with an added
hour of flight time
well the uk government is set to
introduce new legislation to crack down
on dirty money in
parliament not dirty money in parliament
but dirty money in london through
russians it's going to happen in
parliament
under the proposals the new laws will
introduce a register of overseas
entities to crack down on foreign
criminals using uk property to launder
money unexplained wealth orders will be
reformed to target more uh corrupt
elites the treasury's ability to take
action against sanctions breaches will
be strengthened a reform of companies
house will also be published today
designed to clamp down on money
laundering and fraud
england and wales will not play against
russia in any international football
fixture for the foreseeable future their
decision adds to a growing list of
measures sporting bodies are taking as
they make a stand against the invasion
of ukraine and sky's shaman freeman
powell is in the newsroom and it does
seem as if sport is
taking a firmer stand against putin
it does yes the fa joins a long list of
sporting bodies which are using whatever
they can whatever powers they have at
their disposal to send a strong message
to russia and to stand in solidarity
with ukraine now i have a statement from
the fa which was released over the
weekend it says that out of solidarity
with the ukraine and to wholeheartedly
condemn the atrocities being committed
by the russian leadership the fa can
confirm that we won't play against
russia in any international fixtures for
the foreseeable future it said this
includes any potential match at any
level of senior age group or para
football and it follows associations of
poland sweden and the czech republic who
also said that they too will not play
against russia for the foreseeable
future some had hoped though that fifa
would expel russia from the world cup
fifa have spoken and made an
announcement but they didn't go that far
instead they said that russia will be
able to play at the world cup but just
not under their name or in their country
instead they will have to play under the
name of the football union of russia for
competitions and they will not be able
to play in russia instead any any
matches that should have been played at
home will have to be played in a neutral
country as well as this spectators will
not be allowed at stadiums flags will
not be flown and the national anthem
will not be allowed to be sung either
but some do not think that this goes far
enough now the president of the polish
fa said that it was totally unacceptable
and had hoped that russia would be
expelled from the competition however
fifa said that this is still an option
and that they wanted to see what
happened and that if the situation
didn't improve rapidly they would be
considering this as well so this is just
the latest announcement from the latest
sporting association
okay shaman thank you very much well the
prime minister boris johnson says the
government will ease visa rules to make
it easier for ukrainians already settled
in the uk to bring their immediate
families over but opposition parties say
britain should follow the eu and open
borders to all
ukrainian refugees who need sanctuary
sadia choudhary has this report
standing in solidarity with ukraine with
other countries throwing open their
doors for refugees of a war-torn nation
many feel that the uk isn't doing
of the enough
of my prime minister because he is not
joining the sanctions
as pressure builds the government is to
change visa rules to make it easier for
ukrainians who are settled in the uk
to bring their families to safety
certainly we want people who are who
have relatives in ukraine to be able to
bring them over as fast as possible we
want to make sure that we have
roots for people fleeing
disaster war persecution in ukraine to
to come here we'll also be partnering up
with some of the of the of the countries
in the immediate vicinity of ukraine to
help uh bring people over and don't
forget the the uk since since 2015 has
been
one of the most generous if not the most
uh welcoming country in in europe
it could offer hope to markian a
bricklayer whose eleven-year-old
daughter lives in ukraine
they are scared
scared by they said
we're just waiting maybe maybe tomorrow
would be better maybe tomorrow stop
everything we don't want to go anywhere
you want to stay at
home this makes me more scary and
nervous
they've been meeting up on video calls
sometimes i just
talking very strange for everyone i said
just go
i said what you can do you just
children and women what we can do there
labour has described the government's
failure to offer a more wide-ranging
visa waiver as shameful
other european countries have announced
an open door policy for ukrainians
seeking sanctuary
world support ukraine but not everyone
wants to leave
one person told us her 68 year old
father was willing to take his hunting
rifle to defend his country
sadia chaudhary sky news in london
and don't forget every day this week
we'll have a special programme twice a
day on the russian invasion of ukraine
we'll bring you the latest news from
across this country as well as our
correspondents in washington westminster
and around europe
that is ukraine invasion at 1pm and 7pm
all this week
well the uk is fast tracking plans to
tackle dirty money prime minister boris
johnson has also pledged to get more
arms to ukraine's military but the
government has been criticized for not
dropping
visa rules for ukrainians uh political
correspondent tamara cohen is in
westminster for us this morning uh this
morning good morning tamara and uh ben
wallace i was interesting i mean he had
a lot to say didn't he about what was
going on here but uh this question of
visas suggesting there may be some more
movement there
i suspect there will be some more
movement on it mark their home office
are looking at it at the moment what
boris johnson said last night you may
have seen pictures of him going to a
ukrainian at church in london and being
applauded by the people there as he lit
a candle he has announced that the visa
rules will be relaxed so if a ukrainian
is living in the uk already they will be
able to bring over their immediate
family that is a spouse children parents
if that person is under 18.
without having to go through the complex
and expensive visa rules so the process
will be much quicker for people who are
in desperate situations but what labour
is saying is this is still too
restrictive that the government should
allow much more family members elderly
parents for example to come over to the
uk and that this is still the process
the government had in place already
they've just speeded it up a bit and
contrasted that unfavorably with what
the eu are doing which is essentially
welcoming all ukrainian refugees for a
period of three years so i suspect the
home office will have to look at that
again in the coming days the refugee
council also saying that it looks a bit
mean-spirited and so the government will
be looking at that they are also
announcing some much stricter sanctions
in the next couple of days including
efforts the home office say to unmask um
the owners of big expensive houses in
the uk that are suspected to have been
bought with dirty money um because the
uk has always allowed um people to buy
properties um through companies
anonymously and not give their name or
the source of that money that's going to
be clamped down on in the coming months
and we've also heard today that the uk
is taking measures against russia's
central bank the chancellor says to try
and cut russia off from international
finance
okay tamara thank you very much indeed
well many people here in kiev have been
waking up in bomb shelters where they've
sought safety from shelling as russian
forces advance uh on the capital city
here well alexi goncharenko is a member
of ukraine's parliament and he joins me
now
from uh kiev and very good to talk to
you alexei thanks for being with us and
ukrainian forces
seem to be putting up quite a fight
not quite a fighter i can say ukrainian
forces are winning that's the reality
the plan putin putin's plan was to take
kiev in two days then he gave them two
more days and i can tell you he can give
them 200 more days or 2 000 more days we
will not surrender like you told i heard
about an 68 year old man who said i will
take my uh rifle hunting rifle and we
will fight and that's about tens of
thousands of people in ukraine me be not
absolutely military person that's what
i'm sitting with and uh
i'm in the
headquarters of one of the territorial
defense battalions and we have a number
of mps there and we're just waiting if
the enemy will enter the city and move
to the center we will go and fight and
defend the parliament so that is
ukrainian parliamentarism not to vote
but to fight with automatic rifle
yeah and alexi how long do you think you
can hold out for
i'm sure that we will hold on uh
you know the time is not here i mean we
will hold on till the moment we will win
that's that's the whole story and when
it will be it depends not only from us
and from our armed forces but certainly
of
western uh countries and free world and
we are waiting for more sanctions
against russian federation the first
steps are good but we need to go further
even kickoff from swift is partial only
a targeted
[Music]
list of russian banks are kicked off and
others are not so these allow putin's
regime to uh find the ways out from the
sanctions also we believe in the ban uh
embargo on russian oil and gas because
it's a bloody oil bloody gas it's full
of ukrainian blood now including
ukrainian children and certainly non-fly
zone i just want to address through
thank you very much through your media
um
uk politicians uh to help us in this
because non-flight zone is something
very important even first of all from
humanitarian point of view because you
know that russians are using aircrafts
and missiles uh to attack residential
areas uh hospitals um kindergartens and
that is awful and people in kiev now you
know that like in london in 1940 in 1940
are sitting in metro stations for hours
each day so that's something that should
be stopped and the nato can help us in
in this just closing our skies we are
not asking for boots on the ground we
are ready to fight for ourselves but in
the skies we really need help
i mean the danger is or the fear is that
nato trying to enforce a no-fly zone
could lead to a much
broader war
uh i can tell you that the fear should
be that if putin would not be stopped
here
there will be much broader work he will
go for forward he will go further he
will go to latvia lithuania estonia
poland georgia it's a hitler he will
never stop no munich because
munich 1938 that's that's he is looking
for but i already see that that will not
happen
we need d-day we need uh landing in
normandy we need something like this to
stop a bigger work and don't forget that
there are other dictatorships throughout
the planet which now are very much
looking at putin and thinking what will
be his destiny and if he would be
successful i'm sure he would not because
of our resistance but if he would be
successful they will also attack attack
their neighbors those who they don't
like so it will be it will be a disaster
so free world should now
show the strength
it's it seems that as you say president
putin miscalculated on many fronts he
miscalculated the resistance
underestimated the resistance of the
ukrainian forces and the ukrainian
people
he seems to have miscalculated on
sanctions he probably didn't think he
was going to get hit quite as hard as he
has but
do you think a cornered president putin
a president putin whose options are
running out becomes a a dangerous
president putin a more dangerous
president putin
let us not say that oh now let us not
corner putin because why putin is
cornered let let him take his forces out
of from ukraine ukraine is not saying
give us moscow we not have any
intentions on russian territory just to
take off from our territory that's all
we want so he's cornering himself
not somebody is cornering him and
quicker he will understand this better
it will be
and just finally and very briefly do you
have any hope at all
that something may result from the talks
that are going on between ukraine and
russia today
you know speaking with russia you need
to have automatical rifle in your hands
and because we have now i think there is
some chance
if not today maybe the next days with a
strong position of the free world they
need to go to the peace talks i believe
in this
okay alexi look thank you very much and
thank you appreciate your time this
morning thank you thank you
right well germany is uh set to sharply
increase its spending on defense in the
wake of the invasion here i'm joined now
from berlin by thomas kleiner brockhoff
the vice president of the foreign policy
think tank the german marshal fund
of the united states he was also adviser
to the former
president of journey jocheim gok thank
you very much for being with us and it's
interesting isn't it germany was
perceived as the weakest link in all
this in terms of supplying
weapons in terms of sanctions
and
things have turned out very differently
oh sure they have it was a memorable day
yesterday in parliament
and not many people including myself
expected it
uh just to play out as dramatically as
it did
the olaf schultz government that was
perceived as hesitant
by some even as weak
and as not having heard
the shot
broke free and
got ahead of the curve
and
enacted and announced
the
biggest foreign policy change
in my lifetime it was a stunning moment
in parliament yesterday
and these are historic changes brought
about
by president putin's invasion of a
well an independent democratic country
mr putin is to uh he plays a big a huge
part in this
the foreign policy community
had for a long time
tried to push success of german
governments
to
open their eyes to a changing
international environment to one in
which
germany's posture
was
was no longer
equivalent and appropriate to
but hadn't been heard
and so yesterday
was the day when
uh
germany the the country as a whole and
you could physically feel it in
parliament
decided to want to stand up to putin i
think the the nuclear threats played
their part
but also the fact that all of schulz
took the trip to moscow
and heard it from the horse's mouth
probably played a part in his in his
calculus
and what happened here was not just a
dramatic increase in defense spending
it was a complete turnaround of the
posture of german foreign policy which
will now
no longer
want to
accommodate and somehow try to get along
even with the the dictator on the
assumption that there is no security in
europe without or certainly not against
russia to a posture of now isolating
russia
being independent and not interdependent
with russia in terms of energy and
certainly then there is a defense factor
yeah well it is hugely significant and
that was to be
my final question to you germany is a
lot more reliant on
well currently on
russian energy than um many other
european countries how badly do you
think
um you know russia will will hit back at
germany
that's exactly the right question we we
can't possibly know that at this at this
stage will they retaliate by reducing
gas flows
and that will
be
the answer to that question because
clearly it is a highly risky move which
they have prepared prepared by
trying to buy
gas on the spot market by re-routing
ships
but all the measures that they want to
want to take will take time to kick in
building
lng ports building national reserves
all of that will take time so the risk
is clearly
in in the short term and be very much
dependent on how mr putin
reacts in the mid and long term
the acceleration
of renewable energy which the finance
minister mr lindner called freedom
energy
is going to be the key
but until then many compromises will
have to be made including the question
whether the last remaining nuclear power
plants
uh which would be effective in base load
will need to be
kept online a tough question for the
greens which is delayed
yeah all uh decisions to be made thomas
uh appreciate your time thank you so
much for being with us
thank you the invasion is taking a heavy
toll on the people here of course the
health ministry has reported that more
than 350 people have been killed while
the un says around 370 000 people have
now fled the country dimitrijo sharon
goski is vice rector at the ukrainian
catholic university and joins me now
from the viv which is over in western
ukraine thank you very much
for being with us first of all how are
things there are the russians
targeting the city where you are live
thank you for having me so not currently
as a situation pretty stable but every
morning we have a few alarms and we have
few alarms per day so they are targeting
not only the military infrastructure but
also civil infrastructure so we can't be
sure
and
the university i gather is helping
people who are moving west who are
moving away
from the main fighting a humanitarian
crisis is clearly unfolding how are you
being able to help
so we turned our institution into the
spot for gathering the humanitarian help
from the citizens from the neighbors but
also from ngos so all the communities
helping both faculty members and
students and every day we have a
thousands of of help that is coming and
we are definitely supporting giving that
to both to army and also to idps who are
coming to western ukraine precisely
so we've take the strategy of being the
primarily place of location
and after that the idps are going to the
smaller towns or to the other cities and
as a university will also host families
of our students from east and southern
part of ukraine
and other idps that are coming to live
and dmitro are the numbers increasing
all the time
yeah indeed that's true so every day we
are having more and more people uh there
are a few troubles with they get in here
so the railway stations are not working
to the great extent uh correctly so
they're working but uh still there are
some limitations and the roads are also
difficult to come because of the great
lines
but you are not uh fearful for yourself
you're prepared to stay and to help
these people who are fleeing cities in
ukraine
students are ready to do this we are
inspired by the possibilities actually
that we can help our society and help
our army so a number of people including
myself so we are registered in the civil
territory defense and after the day we
are patrolling and vivial coins for the
streets and checking is everything is
correct so everybody is doing something
like to secure the situation to be sure
that neither russian invader nor
other people are doing some harm to the
city property and to the people
and what do you make of this
spirit of resistance that exists clearly
where you are and also clearly from what
we've seen you know across uh ukraine
what do you make of that
so we are well prepared for that and
this is uh the chance of us to to unite
definitely and to resist
so uh the so-called maidan spirit is
here everybody is helping everyone with
what we can do
and this is a great story of the
decentralization of power when in the
cities the civil society can take
responsibility and also help other
authorities to do their best
and just briefly in 20 seconds or so you
yourself and your other students are
prepared to carry on doing this whatever
happens uh with this invasion
sure sure this is our obligation this is
our country and they're definitely doing
that
okay uh dimitri i appreciate your time
uh thank you very much for being with us
uh this morning
thank you for having me
so the situation here in the capital
kiev is uh quiet at the moment but
the russian forces are massing we know
of a long column a three and a half mile
column of russian infantry vehicles
closing in on the capital
but this morning as yet it remains
reasonably quiet on day five
of this invasion
[Music]